barry lawler spent more than
50 years playing and working for local
football teams
but in 2012 he was diagnosed with
dementia
and died just two years later his
daughter donna is convinced
trauma to his head during games played a
huge part
in his death the era of the
old brown leather footballs
my dad always used to say heading one of
those
when wet was like heading the level of
concrete
it is it's obvious that that
is what eventually killed him
the thing he loved most in the world
was the thing that killed him
donna's story tallies with new research
from university college london
it's found people who experienced head
injuries in their 50s or younger all
scored lower
on cognitive tests at the age of 70.
we found that people who had a head
injury had worse performance and memory
tests
and some tests on processing and speed
and thinking and also some differences
and some of the structure of the brain
so we were able to look at lots of
different measures of brain health and
the measures that were affected
or linked with head injury were those
structural changes
the research involved testing 502
participants
a fifth of whom had previously suffered
a head injury
this study adds further evidence on how
head injuries
can lead to long-term effects on the
brain
but the research team is keen to stress
that it's not just those
involved in sport who can be affected
the authors say the study shows anyone
who has suffered head injuries in early
or midlife
may see a small but significant impact
on their brain's health
this study didn't look specifically at
sports injuries and so i think that's a
really important
distinction to make but i think
one of the things that
we need to always consider is whilst the
evidence
comes in to try and reduce risk of
traumatic brain injury wherever possible
it's hoped the research will do more to
raise awareness of how head injuries
can impact our lives including how they
may make people
more vulnerable to symptoms of dementia
dan whitehead sky news
in cardiff